Is there anything you can recommend to increase energy?
Okay, good question.
Anything you can recommend to increase energy?
Bear question, but I would not be a good doctor
if I didn't ask a question of a question, right?
And the question to this question would be asking
the question line.
So why does a person, you've got to find out why a person has
a low energy?
So yeah, do you want to increase energy?
What does the world tell you to do?
Well, you take that energy, drink,
go, you drink some caffeine or something like that.
Well, that's not treating the real cause
of the decrease energy.
So you've got to look at, okay,
what's causing my decrease energy?
So what could be causing decrease energy for anyone?
You know, whether you're a cancer patient or not.
Well, the first thing that you think of is an anemia.
So an anemia is when you have low red blood cell count
or low people go with both.
If that's the case,
that's definitely going to decrease your oxygen
carrying capacity of your red blood cells.
And that's going to decrease the energy
that you're getting to the brain.
That's where you're really going to feel the decrease energy.
So a person says, I don't have any energy.
They're not getting good oxygen carrying capacity to the brain.
So treating the anemia,
so treating the cause of the decreasing energy,
in this case, anemia is the most important thing.
So if the person has anemia with cancer,
do look at our blog post about treating anemia with cancer,
but definitely you're going to look
at about adding some iron.
And if you're going to add some iron,
think about adding some artimicid as well.
If your pad iron, you should always add artimicid
and take them together.
Because the problem with anemia with cancer
is that cancer can gobble up iron.
And if you're going to,
if it's going to gobble up iron,
well, that's artimicidid right with it.
So artimicid binds to iron to have information
on the blog post about that.
Artimicid binds to iron.
And artimicid can be a cancer killer.
So we're giving the option,
if the cancer is going to gobble up the iron,
it's going to gobble up the artimicidid too.
And we could actually kill the cancer via the artimicid.
So treating the anemia, treating the cause.
Let's say I have anemia due to something else.
Let's have anemia due to an infection
or let's have lack of energy due to an infection,
a chronic infection.
That's not an uncommon thing, a chronic infection.
How would you know that?
That would you know if your white blood cell cult
is about seven, maybe seven point five,
that's in the normal range.
If you look at a white blood cell test,
if you look at a CBC test, typically,
both labs are going to say normal white blood cell cult
is 4.5 to 10.5, or maybe even 11.
But really if you have a white blood cell cult
over 7.5, you do have a hidden infection.
That could be a cause of that of the decreased energy.
You could have just inflammation.
So chronic inflammation can be a cause of decreased energy.
So that could be due to food sensitivities, food allergies.
I met people with hidden food allergies of gluten
and it causes inflammation in the brain
and that causes just a decrease of energy.
And they get really super sleepy
and can't figure out why I need to be take the drink
and coffee in the afternoon.
I feel like I need to take an amp.
It's probably because they're eating a food
that they have sensitivity to.
How would you find that out?
Run a Cyrex panel.
Typically a Cyrex array 10 gives you a test of 200,
100 different foods cooked and raw
that would give you a good broad panel
of do I have food sensitivity that I need to look at?
Remember, your cheeks won't be testing
is not going to test for antibodies to foods.
So you might have, I might have taken you off of,
let's say dairy or pork or something like that.
That doesn't mean you have a food sensitivity
to those things that means that's driving your cancer.
You could have food sensitivities that is i.e.
Antibodies, two different foods or peptides
in different foods that can cause you all sorts
of comorbidities.
So you might have cancer and you might have a decreased energy
totally caused from the cancer, but you could have cancer
and you could have a comorbidity of decreased energy
and it's caused from a totally different condition.
That isn't even tied to the cancer.
Usually if you have anemia with cancer,
that's tied to the cancer.
But you could have a chronic infection
that's not tied to the cancer.
You could have inflammation due to food sensitivities
or food antibodies that's not tied to the cancer.
You could have another totally different disorder
and most commonly would be an autoimmune disorder.
So looking at that might be a thing.
So looking if you have an autoimmune condition
would be and that would be, you know,
should be a contact call with baby
because we need to talk about that.
But how you attest for that is you would do a Syrex array.
Five, if you thought it was an autoantibodies
to peripheral tissues or a seven X
if you thought it was antibodies to neural tissue.
So that's Syrex labs is the best labs to look for antibodies.
So we can go through that.
So no, there is it is, you know, let's say it's none of these.
And let's say, you know, a common cause for a decrease,
just a mild decrease energy can be an adrenal fatigue.
You know, you're getting just, you know,
just fatigue from all the weirdness of treating your,
let's go to the computer, treating your cancer
and treating your, you know, whatever,
you just have the adrenal fatigue
and some low energy from just a hormone suppression,
common with people that are dealing with chronic disease
and all kinds.
And then you'd think of what would you do for that?
You'd think of adaptogens.
So adaptogens are different nutrients
that can just help bring up the aderitals,
can calm down a hyperadrenal state,
can just kind of balance your hormones
and can really help you with anxiety
and with stress issues,
chronic stress can certainly cause adrenal fatigue,
and then you end up with a decreased energy.
So that, the obviously this is super fun
with anybody dealing with cancer
or any other, you know, disease long term.
And this can be addressed with just adaptogens.
The beauty of adaptogenic herbs is that you can't take
too many of them, you know, you just can't.
And it just helps bring balance.
So if your aderitals are, are fatigued,
it can help bring that up.
And if your aderitals are in overdrive,
cause you're just in a stress state,
it can help bring that down,
hence adapting you to the environment.
That's where it can stay.
So those are some things that you think of.